pour l'instant les combats se concentre
on l'a vu surtout dans l'est du pays et
Emmanuel Macron est en train de parler
on va l'écouter
elle est là
et nous sommes prêts
à cet acte de guerre nous répondrons
sans faiblesse avec sang-froid
détermination et unité
nous prendrons des décisions lors du G7
cet après-midi du Conseil européen qui
se tiendra ce soir à Bruxelles et du
sommet de l'OTAN qui se tiendra dans les
prochaines heures
nous demanderons à la Russie de rendre
des comptes au Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies et tâcheront de bâtir
l'unité internationale
les sanctions portées à la Russie seront
à la hauteur de l'agression dont elle se
rend coupable sur le plan militaire et
économique autant que dans le domaine de
l'énergie nous serons sans faiblesse
nous appuierons l'Ukraine sans hésiter
et nous prendrons toutes nos
responsabilités pour protéger la
souveraineté et la sécurité de nos
alliés européens
mes chers compatriotes
les événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'Europe et
de notre pays
ils auront des conséquences durables
profondes sur nos vies ils auront des
conséquences sur la géopolitique de
notre continent
et nous serons ensemble y répondre
je veux vous dire ma détermination à
vous protéger sans relâche
protéger nos compatriotes exposées en
Ukraine protégées tous les Français et
prendre les décisions qui s'imposeront
quant aux conséquences directes et
indirectes de cette crise
en 16 heures troubles ou renaissent les
fantômes du passé et où les
manipulations seront nombreuses
ne cédons rien de notre unité
unité autour de nos principes de liberté
de souveraineté et de démocratie
c'est principe nous ont fait et
continuent de nous tenir ensemble
un message de ma part sera prononcé
demain au Parlement et je reviendrai
vers vous dans les heures qui viennent
afin de vous tenir informé de
l'évolution de la situation
et des décisions que je serai amené à
prendre
vive la république et vive la France